[Music]
the earth has been hurtling towards
Jupiter for the past 242 days and now
it's about to make impact now we're so
close to the giant planet that it's the
only thing that fills our sky ground
temperatures on earth are rising
uncontrollably our atmosphere is
igniting into flames and the scientific
community is scrambling to provide
answers what will happen when the two
planets collide is there any chance that
we could pass right through the gas
planet and how would this collision
transform Jupiter forever
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter swallowed earth one
way that scientists could find answers
would be by looking into the past
because this wouldn't be the first time
that Jupiter has collided with another
planet nearly four and a half billion
years ago Jupiter was involved in a
violent collision with a planet ten
times the mass of the earth in that case
the collision completely transformed
Jupiter's core but what happened to the
other planet and what can that tell us
about our own planets chances of
surviving a crash into the gas giant
to get some answers let's travel back to
four and a half billion years ago when
Jupiter was just a young planet trying
to find its place in the universe back
then Jupiter's gravitational pull became
30 times more powerful in just a
fraction of a million years this
destabilized the orbits of nearby infant
planets and caused some of them to crash
into Jupiter it's believed that one such
planet was ten times the mass of earth
and it was mainly a silicate I scorned
the planet hit Jupiter with an impact
speed of 46 kilometers per second
Jupiter only lost a small amount of mass
from the collision but its original core
was completely changed before the impact
Jupiter had a dense central core of
heavy elements and the rest of the
planet was made up of hydrogen and
helium after the impact the infant
planets silicate ice core merged with
Jupiter's causing Jupiter's core to
become diluted the heavy elements spread
out and mixed with the outer layers of
Jupiter while this collision was a
defining moment for Jupiter it meant the
end of the road for the other planet
so what are the odds that the Earth's
fate would be any different well let's
find out the earth orbits around the Sun
at an average velocity of 29 point seven
eight kilometers per second at this
speed if the earth were to just leave
its orbit around the Sun and heads
straight for Jupiter it would take about
240 two days to get there throughout our
journey Jupiter would shine like a
bright star growing bigger day by day
hour by hour by day six Jupiter would
appear as bright as our moon soon we
would start to notice our daylight
becoming dimmer we'll only get about 50%
of our normal sunlight when we reach
Mars's orbit luckily for us the Earth's
atmosphere would act as a buffer so we
wouldn't experience the cold right away
but that will only last a while so
you'll need to invest in some heavy-duty
winter gear to put it in perspective
Mars has a surface temperature of minus
63 degrees so that's basically what we'd
have to look forward to once we speed
through Mars's orbit will pass through
the asteroid belt we'll get to see
beautiful meteor showers lighting up the
sky but we'll also be at risk with
colliding with some of those meteors so
let's keep moving
after 242 days of traveling through our
solar system we would finally reach our
destination Jupiter as the earth is
pulled into Jupiter our planet's
velocity could increase until it reaches
60 kilometers per second
that's 250 times faster than an airplane
flies so you want to hold on tight oh
and did we mention that Jupiter has 79
confirmed moons orbiting it at all times
so there's a serious risk that we could
collide with any of them as the earth is
pulled in closer and if we do happen to
avoid all those moons things would only
get worse as we crash into Jupiter both
planets atmospheres will be compressed
rapidly increasing the temperature and
essentially setting the air on fire but
at least we won't have to worry about
colliding with Jupiter's core because
we'll never make it there our planet is
too small and would burn up in the
atmosphere before that ever happens but
this would have a huge impact on Jupiter
as the Earth's remains would completely
mix into its atmosphere so if you ever
notice our planet going off course and
heading towards Jupiter you might want
to jump off along the way maybe right as
we pass over Mars and if you want any
pointers on how to make the Red Planet
your new home check out our new show how
to survive the advice you find there
might help you set up your own little
Martian colony but that's a story for
another what if
[Music]
[Music]